qualify as an original song score a  score must contain five original songs  songs that serve a dramatic purpose that  move the story along so the nominees for  Best Original Song score are for The  Muppets Take Manhattan Jeff Moss for  Purple Rain Prince  and for a songwriter Kris Kristofferson  and the winner of a brand-new 84 Oscar  is the winner is Prince for cutaway  thank you very much this is Lisa and  this is Wendy this is very unbelievable  I could never imagine this in my wildest  dreams and I would like to thank the  Academy mr. Albert Magnolia my manager  Stephen Bob Joe Bobby  mark and Matt who could be with us today  and most of all God thank you very much  you